I just saw where Live Nation announced
the drive-in concert series and Darius
Rucker is going to be part of that
concert goers will be able to drive into
parking lots of amphitheaters with a
maximum of four people per car tickets
go on sale this Friday Darius is going
to be performing at Nissan Stadium July
12th in Nashville that's a pretty good
idea a cool idea Darius joins us on the
program what's the longest you've gone
without performing in front of a crowd
no matter what sighs what do you miss
most about it the being on stage is just
the feedback of the crowd I miss that so
much I know you know you always could
you know if you were taking two weeks
off for two weeks off you always had
that show in the calendar that was there
you know when you were gonna play again
see I think I took it for granted a lot
and now look at the calendar not knowing
when you know play again was tough and
it really made me realize how much I
love doing what I do
we've talked about the smallest crowd
you played in front of with the Blowfish
when you guys first started out like you
could it was it like less than 20 yeah
[Laughter]
what's the single biggest crowd you
performed in front of in 94 the two
biggest guys who played for in 90 I
think 95 we played in East Lansing
Michigan is a festival there was 72,000
people there and then in Charleston we
played a festival they had like do you
know like does it matter if it's 20,000
60,000 does it matter to you with the
energy or with the venues you don't even
know I mean once you get that many
people in there you look at you go oh
goodness is a lot of people but the
energy is the same the oddest band that
you opened for oh my goodness the artist
hasn't weird or like artists as a nod
bands well wouldn't match your music oh
we open up for Alex children one day
yeah we are wheeled around children at a
club one day yeah he didn't like us very
much who else did you guys open up for
oh goodness back of the day you know I
told the Wet Sprocket up for a big head
time the monsters in our first big tour
and you know those tours both were the
same way we started opening up for the
guys by the end of the tour whoo take it
off and I felt bad but you know I I was
there with Toad the Wet Sprocket Oh and
toad was big at the time and then all of
a sudden I check back in with you at the
end of the tour and it was and ladies
and gentlemen please welcome Toad the
Wet Sprocket and then that would be the
opening band I went oh oh what just
happened because I would get there early
so I could see you guys that I realized
that you guys were the headliner there
all of this stuff there's a couple of
things I wanted to talk to you about as
long as I've known you which is I think
26 years you've talked about South
Carolina getting that Confederate flag
down off the the State Capitol that has
happened you see what's happening with
Bubba Wallace at NASCAR events you have
gone and performed at NASCAR events you
know what was that feeling like did you
ever feel uncomfortable when you went
it's singing the anthem there's no two
ways about that no that's just an
uncomfortable feeling so yeah I found a
comfortable you know what happened to
Bubba I mean I read that yeah I really
cried that I thought wow that's really
still where we are and if somebody
thought that was a cool thing to do go
do that too you know that's just
unbelievable that that sad that sad that
we're still that there in the world and
you see these videos of people I mean I
saw the video yesterday with a woman who
was yelling at his crowd that she's
gonna teach her grandkids to hate you
know like what is happening in the world
right now it was done believable have
you been I'm a bubble yeah it was a
great dude man I mean you know it was a
great guy and you know Richard Peddie
for Richard Peddie to put him in a you
know in a car and then Institute that
was huge for
the 43 car to the legendary 43 car that
was driven by the king and owned and
owned by the king now you know and it's
like it's just that that's just I love
what NASCAR did I I thought it was a big
strong move to make the statement they
made you know and I guess the hatred is
making their statement - how did you
process you know what happened in
Minneapolis I watched that video once
and couldn't watch it again to watch a
guy dial dye we watch the guy die and it
didn't have to happen and it breaks your
heart and you know what American I love
this country and I just you see that you
just go man we got to do better and you
see all this the protests and everything
this is the first time I felt like it
was different you know I usually feel
like okay we're gonna people yell and
scream I'm gonna talk about there's
gonna change but this time I feel like
things are changing but I've been around
you and you know people treat you
differently because you're famous but
I'm sure you've been driving in a car
and they don't know you're famous but
they know you're driving a nice car and
you get pulled over you happen sometimes
you know and you know they pulled me
over and they see me and you know all of
a sudden they make something up and you
know and then they check get my driver's
license let me go but it's like it
happens all the time it's just you know
it seems like it's the way of life in
our country that happens but I don't
know if you talked to you know your wife
about your son Jack that you know he's a
teenager now of just that fear like what
what is the world and and you know he's
gonna be susceptible to all these things
that were watching now or there's that
possibility of that being out there you
know it's you don't want your kids to go
through that stuff like like the thing
that happen above I can imagine if that
was my son you know I mean and in you
got to talk about it is sad that you
have to talk to your kid about you know
getting stopped by the police or you
know the racism that's in the world on
stuff it's sad but you have to talk
about it because it's real because we
Limited every friggin day and I don't
know I was there in the beginning but I
didn't understand it
like you guys had to hear that you had
to hear this when you're performing
people would say stuff to you right I
don't know if you heard it but you know
these your your guys the band they
wanted to go fight like let's stop the
concert let's go out and find somebody
you gotta figure we're playing in in
1989 and 1990 we're playing these frat
houses in the SEC you know all over the
southeast and you know man the racist
stuff that was said you know there's you
know it's it's we want to fight a lot
but we knew that we couldn't find our
way out of those frat house but there
was the one time though you guys I can't
imagine some of the guys in the band
throwing down but didn't you have
somebody that they did something across
the street and then you this was the
same night we met Tiger Woods you know
we're leaving a we're leaving a bar and
there's some guys across the street they
start saying some stuff and start
throwing throwing snowballs at it then a
few a snowball at me with a bottle in it
and so it's me and Sony were the first
to walk in and you know Dean's the
passive one mark is a nice guy but me
and Sony are ready to go at any minute
well you tell the story I know I have
you tell it all the time but when when
you got in a fight in the bar and you
know the embarrassment of getting beat
up by hooting the Blowfish or your last
line to these guys we just beat these
guys up I mean there's five ounces and
we beat these guys I mean it was
shocking and so we're leaving and I'm
mouthing off for the owner shows up it
goes what's happening what's that
man you need to get some new bouncers
you said what do you mean I said I love
that I love that story oh my God we're
talking to Darius Rucker and if you're
in Nashville
July 12th its it's driving concert
concert goers will be able to drive into
the parking lots of the amphitheaters
with the maximum four people tickets go
on sale this Friday how many people are
you gonna be able to get in these
parking lots yeah I'd really have no
idea I mean the thing is the parking lot
is so friggin huge I don't know how many
people are planning on doing but man I
tell you I'm ready to go play a show and
Brad Paisley's gonna do this are you
with Brad Paisley on that bill I think
it's three different nights I think it's
like Friday Saturday Sunday and I'm
doing Sunday I think every night in one
band because you know you can't switch
the bands out and stuff like that oh
okay did Keith Urban do one of these
yeah Keith I think keep it the kind of
first one that started everybody with
the idea huh that's cool I haven't asked
you about your dolphins next season
they're gonna be Super Bowl champs in
February in Tampa don't do that now
don't do that don't do that don't do no
because you know football but you don't
act like it when you talk about the
Dolphins but the Dolphins gonna make you
cry whether they win or lose that's true
that's true it's been a while since
you've cried because they did something
well right I still that darius named his
daughter after Dan Marino but why didn't
you name your son after Dan Marino
you could have named your son Shula we
thought about it did you know we have a
dog named Shula we do wait
so you say to your wife hey I'm gonna no
matter if it's a boy or girl we're gonna
we're gonna name it after Dan Marino my
daughter was conceived at uh Anna Marie
and Don Shula's I think retirement or
Dan at Dan's retirement and uh in our
hotel room there was a life-sized
picture of Dan over my over our bed so
she thinks you you got in the mood
because you can look at it oh look at
number 13 it's so hot that's one of the
creepiest things you've ever told me
I mean you honey I love you too hey it's
good to talk to you looks like alright
McLovin bashes the Beatles all the time
he says they're over 80 to go back to
you
McLovin if you ever say it in front of
me swear to god we're going and you know
no questions asked we're going you're
smarter than that the Beatles are the
single most important musical entity I'm
talking about Beethoven Bach all that
stuff the single most important entity
in the history of music Beethoven every
band that place today is opposed by the
Beatles they might not know it because
they are fluence by some other band
that's influenced by the Beatles but
every band today isn't nearly the
Beatles are your dolphins you can't be
rational about this
nope you just smoked crack Wow bye dad
you made Joe Montana get mad at me the
nicest guy now you make a Darius battery
you know I just put it out there because
you got a Beatles t-shirt on and I
thought no maybe he should know okay the
Beatles are the best like they're in
their own category there's nobody at
number two just out of respect to the
Beatles who would be three on the list
Oh
okay and I didn't and I honestly didn't
think that's all read case book when I
read key spoke at what this band is very
important to the music community
okay what about Ben are you talking
about musical person like if I put
prints in there or Elvis or anybody like
if I put individuals and bands together
on a list Beatles still one is our
stones still two like that's tough
because prints and stones and Marvin
Gaye Sinatra ah true you know yeah yeah
I don't think about that did you meet
Prince once did he talk to you briefly
because he was a different cat man there
me people would say he might say
something to you he might not know who
you were oh good yeah cuz you'd hate for
him to say and what do you do for a
living
but does that where somebody says oh you
know they did hold my hand hooting the
blow fit do you think no was that a show
and like he didn't do meet and greet but
like my manager set up a meet and greet
just for me and my family and yeah just
said oh it's nice to meet you and then
that was it and then just went down it's
good to talk to you hopefully we'll
cross paths here soon everybody thank
you that's Darius Rucker